Ubisoft has revealed its Battle Royale
FPS called hyper scape and I know what
you're thinking another Battle Royale
while it has many of the core tenants
you'd expect from the genre hyper scape
is trying some new things let's run down
everything that makes it unique revives
and responds when players die they're
not necessarily out of the game instead
they turn into invisible entities that
can still run around the map they just
can't do anything other than move what
this means is that dead teammates can
effectively be Scouts by spotting
enemies and watching their movements for
teammates who are still fighting this
makes death less of a punishment it
keeps you invested in the game and
further encourages communication even if
you die to respawn a teammate you need
to find a restore point which is created
where any opponent dies the dead player
needs to sit on it while an active
teammate revives them it can make for
aggressive play since you have to defeat
an opponent or track down a dead enemy
to bring back a teammate loot and gear
progression hyper scape doesn't feature
tears and colors for loot instead all
gear can be upgraded up to four times
throughout a match by finding duplicates
of them for example if you have an
assault rifle and loot another one it
then gets upgraded with a slight
magazine capacity increase and damage
boost in practice this incentivizes
looting even after you found your
favorite loadout special abilities are
called hacks which you'll also loot
during a match since the game's
characters don't function like heroes
you can custom fit which two abilities
you want when you find them on the map
it adds a bit of a strategic layer since
you could swap hacks throughout the
match and use the two you find most
effective in tandem hacks don't have
limited uses instead they run on
cooldown timers some of my favorites
were the teleport - temporary
invisibility a massive wall and a super
bouncy hamster ball like weapons you
have to loot duplicates of the same hack
to upgrade it which gets you shorter
cooldown timers
being crowned the winner you don't
necessarily have to be the last one
standing
to win in hyper scape when it gets down
to the last few squads a crown will
spawn on the map players can pick up the
crown which will then start a 45 second
countdown
if the crown holder can stay alive for
the entire 45 seconds their team wins
however the crown holders location will
be revealed to all the remaining players
when it's picked up leaving them open
for attack if your team thinks
tactically though you can set yourself
up to defend the crown holder or
effectively dodge death but if another
team picks it up
you better get after them fast how the
map shrinks players aren't forced in
from a deadly closing circle like most
battle Royales hyper escapes map is
designed to resemble a small city and
it's cut up and distinct chunks or
districts as the match progresses whole
sections get chopped off this is to
prevent situations where a circle would
awkwardly enclose players and buildings
and this prioritizes the intended map
design arena shooter vibes combat
encounters and hyper scape remind me of
Unreal Tournament or quake you have
double jumps jump pads no fall damage
and a fairly high time to kill it's fast
paced and the map is designed with
verticality in mind and your weapons
reflect the more arcade style feel you
have rocket launchers grenade launchers
chain guns shock rifles and more
conventional guns that function
similarly to how they do in arena
shooters rather than spotting players
from afar and then cutting them off with
a well-placed shot you'll initiate
fights with the intention of starting a
head-to-head shootout twitch audience
participation viewers on twitch streams
can participate in the game as well
hyper scape features a twitch extension
that lets a streamers viewers vote on in
match events these can range from
allowing triple jumps unlimited ammo
speed boosts and more for a short period
of time eventually viewers will also
gain in-game rewards and advance their
battle passes by participating streamers
will also be able to invite viewers to
squads easily through that twitch
extension however these features will be
implemented at a later date so those are
the notable features that can help hyper
scape stand out in the battle royale
space as of this video Ubisoft is
running a technical test currently only
on PC there are sure to be more details
on the game soon and when they come you
can find them here on GameSpot
you
[Music]